the thermodynamic favorability of a
chemical reaction can be affected by the
temperature let's say we have a generic
reaction where the reactants turn into
the products as a quick review when the
standard change in free energy delta g
naught is less than zero the forward
reaction is thermodynamically favorable
therefore the net reaction goes to the
right to make more of the products and
when delta g naught is greater than zero
the forward reaction is
thermodynamically unfavorable that means
that the reverse reaction is favorable
and the net reaction would go to the
left to make more of the reactants
one way to calculate delta g naught is
to use the following equation delta g
naught is equal to delta h naught minus
the absolute temperature times delta s
naught and since delta h naught is
talking about the standard change in
enthalpy
for this equation delta h naught will be
called the enthalpy term and because
delta s naught is talking about the
standard change in entropy the absolute
temperature times delta s naught will be
referred to as the entropy term so when
we're trying to figure out if delta g
naught is negative or if delta g naught
is positive we need to consider the sign
for delta h naught the sign for delta s
naught and sometimes we also need to
consider what the temperature is
there are four possible combinations of
sines for delta h naught and delta s
naught as we can see in this table for
each of these four combinations we're
going to think about the temperatures at
which delta g naught is less than zero
and we're going to finish filling out
this table
to start with we're going to think about
the situation where delta h naught is
negative and delta s naught is positive
so for this first possible combination
when delta h naught is negative we say
that's an exothermic reaction and when
delta s naught is positive that's saying
there's an increase in entropy as
reactants turn into products so let's
think about the sign for delta g naught
if we plug in some numbers for delta h
naught temperature and delta s naught
and when i plug in some numbers i'm not
really concerned about a particular
reaction i'm not concerned about units
i'm not concerned about significant
figures i'm just interested in looking
at the numbers and seeing how the math
affects the sign for delta g naught so
for delta h naught i'm saying that's
negative 100
for the
for t i'm saying that's 100 and for
delta s naught i'm saying that's
positive 0.1 so this would be equal to
negative
100
minus 10 which is equal to negative
110. so delta g naught is negative
notice how a negative enthalpy term
favors getting a negative value for
delta g naught and notice how a positive
entropy term since we're subtracting
that in our equation is also favorable
for getting a negative value for delta g
naught also notice no matter what we put
in for the temperature since delta s
naught is positive the entropy term will
always be positive and since we're
subtracting it in our equation we would
always get a negative value for delta g
naught
so whenever delta h naught is negative
and when delta s naught is positive
delta g naught will be negative no
matter what the temperature
so if we go back to our chart for our
first possible combination
when delta h naught is negative that's
favorable and when delta s naught is
positive that's also favorable therefore
delta g naught is less than zero at all
temperatures so i'm gonna go ahead and
write in here at all temperatures in our
chart as an example of this let's
consider the conversion of ozone gas
into oxygen gas since energy is released
this is an exothermic reaction and delta
h naught is negative and since we're
going from two moles of gas on the
reactant side to three moles of gas on
the product side that's an increase in
entropy so delta s naught is positive
since delta h naught is negative and
delta s naught is positive
delta g naught for this reaction is less
than zero at all temperatures
that means the forward reaction is
thermodynamically favorable and ozone
gas would turn into oxygen gas and this
reaction would occur at all temperatures
the second possible combination for the
signs is when delta h naught is positive
and when delta s naught is negative when
delta h naught is positive that's an
endothermic reaction and when delta s
naught is negative there's a decrease in
entropy going from reactants to products
once again we're going to plug in some
numbers and solve for delta g naught so
for delta h naught let's say that's
positive 100
for the temperature term let's say
that's 100 and for delta s naught let's
say that's negative 0.1 when we do the
math we get positive 100
minus
negative
10 which is equal to
positive
110 so delta g naught is positive notice
when the enthalpy term is positive
that's not favorable for getting a
negative value for delta g naught and
when the entropy term is negative since
we're subtracting this negative we would
actually be adding the entropy term and
that would not favor a negative value
for delta g naught
also notice no matter what you put in
for the temperature here you're always
going to get a negative value for the
entropy term and if the enthalpy term is
positive since we would mathematically
be adding the entropy term we would
always get a positive value for delta g
naught so whenever delta h naught is
positive and delta s naught is negative
delta g naught will be positive no
matter what the temperature so going
back to our chart when delta h naught is
positive that was not favorable and when
delta s naught was negative that was
also not favorable so it doesn't matter
what the temperature is delta g naught
will not be less than zero therefore on
our chart here we can write in at no
temperature will delta g not be less
than zero as an example of this let's
look at the reverse of the reaction we
saw for the first possible combination
before we had ozone turning into oxygen
gas and now we have oxygen gas turning
into ozone because heat is on the
reactant side we know this reaction is
endothermic and delta h naught is
positive and since we're going from
three moles of gas on the reactant side
to two moles of gas on the product side
that's a decrease in entropy and delta s
naught is negative since delta h naught
is positive and delta s naught is
negative
delta g naught will never be less than
zero it doesn't matter what the
temperature is and so the forward
reaction is always thermodynamically
unfavorable
the third possible combination of sines
has both delta h naught and delta s
naught as being negative once again
we're going to plug some numbers into
the equation and see what happens to the
sine of delta g naught so let's say
delta h naught is negative 100 the
temperature is 100 and delta s naught is
negative 0.1 doing the math we get
negative 100 minus negative 10 so that's
negative 100 plus 10 which is equal to
negative 90. let's think about why we
got a negative value for delta g naught
the enthalpy term is negative which
favors a negative value for delta g
naught the entropy term is also negative
but since we're subtracting the entropy
term it actually gets added for the
overall delta g not calculation so the
entropy term is not favorable however in
this case the favorable enthalpy term
outweighs the unfavorable entropy term
and that's the reason why we get a
negative value for delta g naught at
this temperature
let's compare the calculation that we
just did at a temperature of 100 which
gave us a negative value for delta g
naught to a similar calculation except
this time we have a much higher
temperature this time it's 2000 but
notice how the values for delta h naught
and delta s naught are the same as
before the reason why we can use the
same values at a different temperature
is because delta h naught and delta s
naught don't change much with
temperature however delta g naught does
change a lot with temperature because at
this higher temperature when we do the
math we see that now we get delta g
naught is equal to positive 100. so at
this higher temperature even though the
enthalpy term is favorable
now the unfavorable entropy term
outweighs the favorable enthalpy term
and gives us a positive value for delta
g naught
therefore at a relatively lower
temperature delta g naught is negative
however at a higher temperature delta g
naught is positive
so when delta h naught is negative
that's favorable but when delta s naught
is negative that's not favorable and we
just saw from the calculations that
delta g naught will be negative at low
temperatures so let's write that in here
in our chart
so far we've been talking about delta g
naught relative to a chemical process
however delta g naught also applies to a
physical process
in this case we're looking at liquid
water turning into solid water so this
is the process of freezing the process
of freezing gives off energy so this
process is exothermic and delta h naught
will be negative going from a liquid to
a solid is a decrease in entropy
therefore delta s naught is negative for
this combination of signs delta g naught
is negative only at relatively low
temperatures
therefore the forward process of
freezing is thermodynamically favorable
at low temperatures and this matches
with what we already know about water
water freezes at a relatively low
temperature
finally let's look at our fourth
combination of sines and that's when
both delta h naught and delta s naught
are positive so let's say delta h naught
is equal to positive 100 delta s naught
is equal to positive 0.1 and first we'll
look at the lower temperature of 100
doing the math we get positive 100 minus
10 which gives us a positive value for
delta g naught and if we do the
calculation at a higher temperature of
2000 notice that delta h naught is still
positive 100 and delta s naught is still
positive 0.1 this time we get negative
100 for delta g naught notice how for
this example at the higher temperature
the enthalpy term is unfavorable for
giving a negative value for delta g
naught however the entropy term is
favorable a positive value for delta s
naught gives a positive value for the
entropy term and since we are
subtracting it the entropy term
outweighs the enthalpy term giving a
negative value for delta g naught
however for the first example at the
lower temperature since the temperature
is lower the entropy term is a smaller
value and is unable to overcome
the unfavorable enthalpy term and that's
the reason why delta g naught ends up
being positive at the lower temperature
so for this combination of signs delta g
naught is negative at higher
temperatures
so for our fourth combination when delta
h naught is positive that is unfavorable
however when delta s naught is positive
that is favorable and we just saw that
delta g naught is less than zero at high
temperatures so i'll go ahead and write
in on our table here
at high temperatures as an example of
this let's consider solid water turning
into liquid water so the forward process
is the process of melting it takes
energy to disrupt the intermolecular
forces of the solid therefore heat is on
the reactant side and delta h naught is
positive melting is an endothermic
process
going from a solid to a liquid is an
increase in entropy therefore delta s
naught is positive
and when both signs are positive our
calculations showed us that delta g
naught is less than zero at high
temperatures
therefore the forward process of melting
is thermodynamically favorable at
relatively high temperatures and this
matches what we already know from
experience at relatively low
temperatures ice does not melt however
at relatively high temperatures ice does
melt
now that we have our chart filled out
let's summarize what we've learned about
these four possible combinations when
delta h naught and delta s naught are
both favorable the forward process is
thermodynamically favorable at all
temperatures when delta h naught and
delta s naught are both unfavorable the
forward process is thermodynamically
favorable at no temperatures or you
could say the forward process is
thermodynamically unfavorable at all
temperatures
when delta h naught is favorable and
delta s naught is unfavorable the
forward process is only
thermodynamically favorable at low
temperatures
and finally if delta h naught is
unfavorable but delta s naught is
favorable the forward process is
thermodynamically favorable only at high
temperatures